turning overseas where U.S Secretary of
State Anthony blinken met with Israeli
Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu
yesterday in his meeting with the
Palestinian Authority president this
morning this comes amid some of the
deadliest violence in the region in
years mts-type is in Jerusalem MTS good
morning
good morning well secretary blinken is
currently meeting with Palestinian
president Mahmoud Abbas as part of
efforts to in his words de-escalate the
situation a situation which was
triggered by a massive Israeli raid in
the occupied West Bank City of Janine
last week where 10 Palestinians were
killed the following day in what's been
described as a quote Revenge attack a
Palestinian gunman opened fire outside a
synagogue in East Jerusalem killing
seven including six Israelis and since
then there's been more acts of violence
carried out by Palestinians and more
raids by Israeli forces in the West Bank
including at least 144 attacks by
Israeli settlers against Palestinians
there the surge in violence comes as
Israel's new government which is
described as the most extreme and
right-wing in the country's history
triggered Mass protests over its plans
to weaken the Judiciary a protest
movement Lincoln appeared to support
when meeting with prime minister
Benjamin Netanyahu but apart from
appeals for harm secretary blinken
hasn't set out any ideas on on how to
de-escalate the situation nor was it
clear whether he'd be offering any
proposals
MTS tied up for us once again in
Jerusalem MTS thank you very much to
Pakistan now with a death toll from a
suicide bombing at a crowded mosque has
now risen to at least 100. the attack
happened inside a compound that also
houses police and counter terrorism
offices in the Northwestern part of that
country and a hospital spokesman said
that most of the casualties were members
of Pakistani police a commander for the
Pakistani Taliban initially claimed
responsibility through a spokesperson
for the group though a spokesperson for
the group later said that attacking
religious sites violates its policy and
it wasn't them Pakistan's prime minister
called terrorism the country's quote
foremost National Security challenge
Russian forces in eastern Ukraine have
launched a new assault with thousands of
troops according to British defense
officials the latest battle is on top of
the continued fighting in the eastern
city of bakmut which has already been
largely destroyed in months of tax
Deborah patta visited the front lines
where Ukrainian forces are using
everything they've got including
surveillance drones to keep control of
that City
is barely recognizable nearly a year of
War has left the city once renowned for
sparkling wine a hollowed out shell
buckmod still holds as the Ukrainian
Battle Cry but only just the sound of
artillery is constant this city has been
decimated and it's deserted barring a
few people still trying to eke out some
kind of living here even a trip to the
Central Square is done with one eye on
the clock
the other on the sky
Cartier commanders
Battalion is helping to prevent Russia
from seizing the city come on come on
much of that battle is directed in
underground high-tech command centers
like this where soldiers use drones to
live stream video from the front line
revealing it in astounding detail like
this dead Russian soldier and shattered
back yards where Russian troops were
recently filmed crawling for cover their
monitoring of the videos and as soon as
they see
the enemy there or the tanks or
something else they just start to shoot
World War one trench warfare meets 21st
century electronic surveillance
games are counted in inches with Russia
throwing waves of soldiers like meat
into the fight we're told
they just keep on advancing over the
bodies of their fallen soldiers third
operative Battalion Commander Anton Zara
rogini said one group is destroyed
another sent in the main work sleep and
eat here in shifts around the clock no
job too menial making sure for now that
on the blood-soaked battlefields just a
few blocks away
still holds for CBS mornings Deborah
patter bakmud